[Music]
after some outstanding films such as
hereditary the witch and ex machina I'm
always excited to see a 24 put out a
horror film so when they announced that
they were doing an original Irish movie
called the hole in the ground naturally
my interest was piqued however the film
falls short slightly of my expectations
and whilst it doesn't measure up to the
seminal hereditary has still are some
enjoyable HEV seat moments that will
keep you invested in the film throughout
the movie itself follows Sara and her
son Chris who have moved to the remote
countryside in order to get away from
Chris's abusive father after discovering
a huge crater like hole in the middle of
the forest Sara slowly comes in with the
impression that Chris is not actually a
son throughout the film we are given red
herrings that support whether this is
accurate or not and the movie does a
great job of keeping you guessing with
hints that Sara may have some form of
psychosis whilst this allows the first
two acts of the film to be engaging when
the third one comes and with it all the
reveals about the movie it feels like it
doesn't quite deliver upon the setup
with a Russia finale and final scene
that doesn't really clear things up it's
rare that horror movie should go beyond
90 minutes and in the few cases that
they have it's been difficult for the
film to sustain the scares however I
actually think that the hole in the
ground could have done with an extra
half hour just to flesh certain things
out as a lot of the answers that we get
feel underdeveloped when they should
probably be things are explored the most
even Sarah's backstory has a lot of
unanswered questions to it and it's
quite frustrating not seen as clearer or
really brought into the park to show her
self-doubt that's not to say it's bad
though and the fact that I want to know
more of these answers cements that I was
indeed invested in the narrative and
willing to see what else this creeper
world
all of the performances in the film are
phenomenal and both Shana kerslake and
James Quinn Maki really make you believe
that they are a fractured family both
add natural nuances to their
performances that make them easy to side
with and throughout the film as bounce
between the two unable to tell which one
was correct in their statements about
their identity atmosphere is also
prevalent throughout the film and the
soundscape of the piece as well as the
long and lingering shots that compañía
really elevate the work in an almost
mesmerizing way that draws you into the
landscape of the piece overall Wells's
may not have secured the best horror
spot for the air as I was hoping there's
still a lot to like here and I think
most people will be satisfied with a lot
of it even if it fails to deliver in the
climax with all that being said the hole
in the ground gets a respectable 7 out
of 10 so are you excited to see the hole
in the ground and if you already have
then please let me know your review in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of the twilight zone
trailer which we link at the end this is
the channel for people who are mad in
the movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]